you may remain seasick for the time
being Mr Jarvis Mr Zahir be very clear
that I'm reading from some typed
sentencing dates copies will be made
available at the conclusion
Matthew King on the 20th of January this
year you pleaded guilty to an offense
alleging the preparation of terrorism
acts and I must now sentence you
span of conduct covered by the
indictment as a sixth month period
between the 22nd of December 2021 and
the 17th of May 2022
in that time you accept you engaged in
conduct in preparation for giving effect
to your intention either commit acts of
Tourism yourself or to assist another to
commit acts of terrorism
by your guilty plea you accept that you
actively desire to travel from the UK to
an area of Syria controlled by ISIS to
participate in Isis activities
that would have involved you using
serious violence yourself
or endangering the lives of others
also by The Plea you accept an intention
to commit an act of serious violence
against the person or endangering the
life of a person here in the UK
specifically either remember the Armed
Forces or a police officer
in the written base of plea it is said
that you have only carried out a
terrorist activity here if your plans to
travel to Syria and to join Isis were
frustrated
the prosecution does not accept that
part of the base of plea both the
prosecution and the defense agree that
this aspect basically does not make any
difference to sentence in this case as
on any view you accept you had an
intention to commit both terrorist acts
and that you made preparations towards
the commission of both types of
terrorist Act
from what has emerged from the police
investigation it is clear that you are
Someone Who develops an entrenched
islamist extremist mindset extreme
anti-western views and that you intended
to commit terrorist acts both in UK and
overseas
at Secondary School you are someone who
dabbled in drugs and where your behavior
became more aggressive you were expelled
from school and attended an educational
unit in Basildon your behavior
deteriorated and it was needed that
you'd often return home stoned and argue
with your mother you move to other
educational units finally leaving
education age 16 without any
qualifications
in 2020 in a conversation between you
and your mother you spoke about finding
faith
as you said you would like to visit a
mosque your mother took you to a mosque
in Chelmsford
you also watched videos about Islam on
YouTube
this appeared at first to have a
positive impact on you
over time you started to wear more
traditional Islamic clothing you ordered
Islamic books and a premise
you were eating any halal food and were
learning Arabic
by May 2021 you were attending the bin
baz mosque in Stratford your family
noted your behavior had become more
extreme
they noted you were having conversations
online with a girl
you told your mother she was a doctor or
a trainee doctor
you also said you wanted to go to Syria
with her in order to help people
some videos you showed your mother were
of a concern to her
they showed motivational chanting people
engaged in heat debated Speakers Corner
when your mother commented about these
having a negative influence on you you
denied it
you became a member of two local
community online groups using the muddy
adulabdi one group the South End
Brothers had 25 to 30 members and the
other South Endura six members
your mother was concerned at some of the
online material you were viewing as to
her it was promoting hatred
when challenged you denied it claimed
you were watching videos to inform
yourself about the history of Islam
you also said you did not believe in
terrorism
but your mother very correctly made
contact with prevent
in December 2021 you registered as a
customer for the knife Warehouse
although you signed up for their
regulated newsletters you did not place
any orders
however soon afterwards in January 2022
you carried out searches on the internet
for Isis knife tactical training and eye
stiff knife tactical training video
I note that the last login to the knife
Warehouse site was on the 3rd of January
in March 2022 you've made notes on your
phone about detonating homemade bombs
later in March 2022 you recorded a video
at Stratford train station on your
mobile
the video shows the back of a uniformed
police officer in other videos you
appear to be noting the location of CCTV
cameras
two days later you bought a pair of
combat specs Ops glasses military style
glasses and military style combat gloves
in April 2022 you used your phone to
record yourself walking near the
barracks of the seventh rifles regiment
with a Nasheed promoting violent
rhetoric overlaid in the recording
the rhetoric speaks of killing with rage
and Hate
in April 2022 you made a derogatory
comment about Imran Khan a former
Pakistani prime minister
your comment Drew condemnation from the
south end Brothers
you then uploaded a video of a still
image of a male holding a knife with
another Nasheed playing in Arabic
as a result you were reported to the
mosque committee at the Essex Jam mosque
and they decided you were no longer
welcome and that you would be asked to
leave if you attended in the future
you were noted by one of those at the
mosque to be talking and on occasionally
joking about Jihad and War
it was noted that your WhatsApp status
has changed to kill the non-muslims
wherever you see them
members of the various mosques you
attended warned you about your behavior
on the 25th of April 2022 you searched
the internet for Usman Khan and Karen
butt along with the London Bridge attack
links to those involved in the terror
attacks on London Bridge and Borough
Market in 2017 and at fishmongers Hall
in 2019
in May 2022 on a number of occasions you
were seen dressed in an army jacket or
bomber jacket you were expressing views
about how to deal with non-believers
also that month you recorded yourself
reciting words in Arabic referring to
Jihad and there are images of you with
captions on the difference between
suicide and masterton and with a black
flag
there is a video you recorded at
strathfield railway station of a police
officer in uniform who appears unaware
of you
on that video you can be heard to say
the following there is another one over
there as well
also in May you were in conversation
online with Miss A
amongst messages passing between the two
of you are comments about taking part in
violent Jihad in Syria
you write as follows when I arrived to
the land of Martyrs my goal is to die on
the battlefield while trying to kill the
kuffa if you can encourage me to do that
then Abdullah
and I just want to die a martyr
miss a responded supportively there were
further exchanges between the two of you
and you made the comment Let's Race for
it in China
on the same day as these exchanges you
searched on the internet for Manchester
bomber terror attack and stratum attack
the following day you search for Salman
avedi on the internet
same day recorded footage of yourself
close to Stratford magistrates called
with four uniformed officers by the
court building
you later posted an image of the
officers on Snapchat with the caption
Target acquired
a few days later you searched the
internet for Jihadi husband and wife
various chat threads discussed arrested
terrorist Defenders unlikely sentences
also in other days in May there were
ongoing chats between you and Missy
there are references to seeing you in
the news Waging War and training for
Jihad
miss a is encouraging in her responses
in one message you write TBH I just want
to get my hands on an American Marine or
a British Marine
they say also responds with
encouragement to that and in graphic
terms
you also sent her an audio message in
which you include how you would get two
marines in a room and then
then to rape each other there are
references to shooting them in the head
and eventually beheading them
the chat between the two of you
continues about violence and mutilating
people
on the 17th of May having attended the
mosque there is footage taken by you of
being close to and by the gates of the
barracks of the seventh rifles regiment
your actions that evening appear to be
reconnaissance
late that evening you make a Google
search on your mobile for Jihadi Jack
and Jihadi John
in the early days of the next day you
carried out more internet searches for
Salman abedi and also on 7-Eleven
the police forced entry to your home
that morning the 18th of May 2022 and
you were detained and arrested
when arrested you made a number of
comments about your faith
your phone laptop and res items were
seized including a Black Flag a leaflet
on the dangers of Isis a notebook with
notes both in English and Arabic on
religious and philosophical views
you were taken to Basildon police
station
whilst there you showed interest in the
tactical vest worn by a police officer
asking if they were Bulletproof you made
a number of other concerning statements
when rearrested following a preliminary
review of your telephone and its
contents on the 19th of May 2022 you
observed as follows I don't believe in
the UK law the only law I believe in is
the law of Allah
when interviewed you gave a prepared
statement saying you had converted from
Christy Christianity to Islam and that
you developed an interest in Islam by
watching YouTube videos
you admitted posting the status update
video in April 2022 this was the
uploading of the still image of a male
holding a knife with a Nasheed playing
in Arabic
you said the purpose was not to
encourage anyone to destroy others
you refer to kufa in Islam as a metaphor
to destroy disbelievers
you wrote the battle is not about the
actual battlefield but rather a battle
against the soul not to sin
you also said that Jihad can be
translated to mean striving against the
wrongful desires of the Soul against the
devil against Hypocrites and
disbelievers
person holding the knife in the video is
portrayed as a soldier
you challenged some of the assertions
and the statements of the police
officers in relation to comments it was
claimed you'd made on arrest but you
then made no comment responses to all
other questions
the police returned to your address on
the 25th of May 2022 to conduct a
further search they then found the
combat specs Ops glasses a camouflage
baseball cap and combat jacket training
shoes a black rucksack containing a
black balacava and a notebook with notes
in Arabic on how to gain more Twitter
followers and the Tactical gloves
whilst in police detention an officer
overheard part of a conversation you had
with your mother when you spoke about
needing to start training if you go to
prison
you said this I'm going to find someone
in prison to train me I need to start to
eat more protein I need to start
training offensive and defensive when I
get out I'm going to be offensive I'm
going to be a machine
I don't care in my eyes I haven't done
anything wrong I'm not guilty but I
might plead guilty because I will get 30
off my sentence Allah says he will
punish the oppressors everywhere will be
surreal or one day when I get out they
will be controlling me they probably
won't let me have a driving license
because I'll probably run people over
during exercise in the yard a few days
later you've made comments while
engaging with officers saying you want
to learn tactical training from an uncle
at the mosque and also if you know what
you're doing with a knife it doesn't
matter if you're small
in relation to martyrdom it was noted
you said as follows people should be
martyred again and die for what they
believe
and that the Tactical training you wish
to take part in would have to be taken
out of the country in a camp
turning to the sentencing guidelines the
maximum sentence for a section five
offense is one of life imprisonment or
in your case custody for life
for an offense committed on or after the
29th of June
2021 sentencing involves consideration
of the application of the dangerousness
provisions and a number of other
statutory Provisions introduced
including those in the counter-terrorism
sentencing act 2021 and the police crime
sentencing a cork set 2022
the 2021 act introduced Cirrus terrorism
sentences an offender an offense under
Section 5 of the terrorism act 2006 is a
serious terrorism offense listed in
schedule 17A of the sentencing Act 2020.
this offense was committed after the
29th of June 2021 and you were over 18
at the time the offense was committed
the first question then is this is the
court of the opinion that there is a
significant risk to members of the
public of serious harm occasioned by the
commission by you of further serious
terrorism offenses or other specified
offenses
this is the same test with an important
addition as for dangerousness
I also have in mind the provisions of
section 274 of the sentencing act 2020
on a required sentence of custody for
life for an offense carrying a life
sentence
I have helpful sentencing notes from
both the prosecution and the defense
I also have a second note from the
prosecution specifically on the issue of
dangerousness and a response submitted
on your behalf
I have a detailed pre-sentence report
dated the 28th of March from an
experienced probation officer I am
grateful to the author for their
detailed analysis and assessment of the
issues in this case
since the last hearing of this case I've
also been provided with further
documents
I have statements from detective
Constable alwarath setting out relevant
information about you and what appears
to be your current attitude or mindset
whilst you've been in custody
the officer has reviewed prison
intelligence where you've made violent
threats to kill behead and chop up staff
have their loved ones follow home and
beheaded behead an Imam and another
prisoner some of those reports date back
to last Autumn some are more more recent
and post-date the preparation of the
pre-sentence report
initially on your behalf it was
submitted the statement of the officer
should be disregarded on the basis that
it was unsubstantiated equivocal and
unproven bad character evidence
I made clear I did not agree with that
assessment it is material that is very
significant in terms of the risk that
have to be assessed
whilst I accepted the weight to be
attached the contents has to be
considered it cannot be ignored
following the last hearing on the 12th
of May DCL warith sent a further request
to hmp at Wandsworth in relation to any
intelligence relevant to so it could be
disclosed and considered
this further request also sought
confirmation as to any adjudication and
or disciplinary action taken against you
I note only one instance of formal
adjudication with a verdict not to
proceed
and in terms of disciplinary action I
note a number of negative disciplinary
actions have been entered by prison
staff
ing the period from June 2022 through to
the 8th of May this year
the further statements set out other
material relevant to the issue of
dangerousness and to Future risk
attached to the statement as I schedule
with all the intelligence material set
out and that schedule runs to some 69
pages
I repeat the observation I set out above
that this material needs to be viewed
and considered in terms of future risks
included within the pre-sentence report
are observations about the interaction
with prevents from November 2020 onwards
and the lack of Engagement
I also note the observations in the
report about you saying you've changed
your attitudes and beliefs and how this
is involved with the material from the
prison an extract of that material that
set out on page seven of that report
the author of the pre-sentence report
also sets out a list of risk factors in
relation to the assessment on
dangerousness
the assessment in the report of of the
level of danger is very high and
allowing for all various features of the
case the author concludes the section of
the report on assessment of the risk of
serious harm with this observation
having considered all the information
about the court May well determine that
the criteria for dangerousness has been
met
the prosecution submit that you are
someone who intended to inflict serious
violence on or endanger the lives of
other people both in the UK and abroad
that intention was not merely transitory
but one you had settled on during a
period of around six months as you set
about preparing to commit those Acts
they also submit that your time in
custody following arrest and charge has
not led to any reduction in the risk you
pose to others if anything they submit
this court should be concerned that you
are someone who does one thing when the
company of other prisoners seeks out
those who share your extremist views but
then say you have been doing the
opposite when in conversation with
professionals
their submission is that this duplicity
only serves the heightened the risk you
pose to others
on your behalf it is submitted that you
are on the path to de-radicalization
it is accepted that your progress may be
imperfect and as yet incomplete that
you've taken significant steps forward
it is now accepted that the
dangerousness test is met
but it has submitted that any risk you
pose can be managed by the imposition of
a sentence under Section 265 of the
sentencing act or a sentence for an
offender of particular concern
if that is not accepted by this court it
is submitted that an extended sentence
with a limited period of extension would
suffice as you will be subject to
owner's conditions on any license
as I've set up the sentencing hearing
was adjourned part heard so it's allowed
more time for those who represent you to
consider the prison intelligence
material and so that they could address
the possibility of a discretionary life
sentence to meet the concerns of the
risks going forward
I have a letter from your mother dated
the 13th of April this year
she sets out her support for you and her
assessment of your progress
she also makes clear that your father
and your sisters will support you whilst
in custody and on your release
she sets out her assessment that your
views have changed in your period in
custody through your engagement with an
ideological mentor and since taking time
to think and reflect
she also sets out the regret you have
expressed to her for your actions
the supplementary note the sentence
submitted on your behalf sets out
extracts from a number of the decisions
of the Court of Appeal on the approach
to discretionary live sentences as well
as addressing issues around age and
maturity
future risk is the key issue in this
case and the real concern is to win if
at all any risk May really reduce or
cease
I have very much in mind your age and
maturity
that people young people mature at
different stages
but that has to be put into the mix
alongside the observations of others and
the views you appear to be expressing to
some
assessing risks is a very different task
in terrorism cases to other types of
cases involving violence
in my judgment the threshold as set out
in section 268 B and for dangerousness
is clearly passed in my judgment you are
someone where there is a significant
risk to members of the public of serious
harm occasioned by the commission by you
of further tourism offenses or other
specified offenses
section 268 B refers to the imposition
of a sentence of custody for life and
section 268 BF the risk of multiple
death condition
further Provisions relevant to that
condition are set out in subsection
three
both the prosecution and the defense
agree that under the current guideline
based on the levels of preparation here
your culpability would come within
category C with harm it is also agreed
that the case Falls within category 3. I
agree with the assessments of both the
prosecution and your Council as the
stage your preparations have got to and
that it is safer to place harm into
Category 3 than the higher category 2. I
note that it would have been easier much
easier for you to attack a police
officer in the street than it would be
for you to join Isis and Syria and so of
the two Terror acts you intend to carry
out the former more likely and the
latter on the evidence as set out
for such a case the start point for
sentence will be one of eight years
custody with a range of sentence of
between 6 and 10 years custody
the prosecution has identified a number
of aggravating factors they submit that
here the offending was motivated by
hostility towards non-believers you were
in possession of extremist material you
were in contact with others who were
also extremists particularly miss a you
use the number of aliases to conceal
your true identity
you intended to commit acts of terrorism
against soldiers and or police officers
and you fail to respond to warnings
about your conduct in particularly from
your family and others in the mosques
whilst some of those factors are
accepted by Mr zaheer he makes
observations as to the applicability of
others
as a general point I agree with Mr
zaheer that I need to make sure that to
the extent these matters go into the
initial categorization I do not double
count
in terms of mitigating factors you are a
previous good character now age 19 20 on
the 3rd of October this year at the time
of the offending you were 18.
looking at the impact of the aggravating
and mitigating fact features I've
identified the start point would in my
judgment be one of nine years custody
it is important to stress the guidelines
also require the court to consider a
minimum terms serious terrorism offenses
and exceptional circumstances should
they apply as well as the impact of a
finding of dangerousness as part of the
sentencing procedure
having reflected on all the facts of the
offense I do not find that the multiple
death condition is met in this case and
so the passing of a serious terrorism
sentence is not required
all are agreed that in those
circumstances where the dangerousness
test has been found to be met the
options open to this court are a
discretionary life sentence an extended
sentence or in need a special sentence
for an offender of particular concern
as I repeat in relation to the option of
a discretionary life sentence I adjourn
sentence on the 12th of May so as to
allow your Council and solicitor to
consider any other material they might
be that might shed more light on your
conduct and your mindset whilst in
custody they have had the opportunity to
do so and today have made further
extensive submissions on your behalf in
relation to that issue
with regard to the type of sentences
that have to be considered I note what
is set out at paragraph 22 of the
Judgment of the Len law Chief Justice in
the case of the crown against marinskas
in relation to discretionary life
sentences
I need to consider the seriousness of
the offense and any previous convictions
on here there are none perhaps most
significantly in this case I need to
consider the level of danger to the
public pays by you and whether there is
a reliable estimate of the length of
time you will remain a danger
and the available alternative sentences
it is also important to note that since
the decision in berinskas Parliament has
passed further legislation with regard
to terrorist offenders that I've set out
it is also important to note the
particular and unique questions that can
arise with the assessment of futurists
of those involved in terrorism
in mitigation Mr Zahir submits in
relation to the offending itself that
regard has to be had to the levels of
preparation in its case that they were
not far Advanced and the risk of death
was very remote
on the second limb and the potential
Commission of an act of terrorism here
he submits the steps or acts taken were
limited in scope of limited utility and
the prospect of an act of terrorism
again remote
in relation to the mindset material and
the online relationship again it is
submitted that it shows a lack of
maturity along with it a degree of
Bravada in a young man
he properly relies on the fact of your
chronological age and the level of
maturity and that you are someone who
has a supportive family
in relation to the prison records he
submits that there are positive reports
of changes
he submits that when you were detained
you were an extremist he invites caution
as to the frustration on your part as
not being seen to be any part of
extremism
he submits that some of the reports show
your candor and your willingness to
openly discuss matters with prison
stones
he observes that you are now an enhanced
prisoner
three periods are set up by Mr sahir but
he submits show the present records and
the materials in a different light
in the course of this hearing Mr Zahir
took the court through those three
periods as I observed in the course of
his submissions it is helpful to have
the full intelligence material in the
case such as this where future risk is
the key issue
Mr Zahir submits on your behalf that the
prison material supports the passing and
extended sentence rather than life
sentence
he concedes and properly says that she
was not someone who is free from
extremism nor that you are somebody
who's not dangerous then he submits the
threshold for a discretion life sentence
is not passed
in my judgment the prison material
presents a very mixed picture
there is some material that supports the
stance adopted by Mr sakir and which is
to your credit as to your openness and
candle
however there is other material that is
pointing in the opposite direction and
is of considerable concern
would you stand please
having reflected on all the matters that
have been set out and summarized in
these remarks and in particular on the
level of danger to the public you pose
and whether there is any reliable
estimate of the length of time you will
remain a danger I am off the view that
there must in this case be a
discretionary life sentence and that is
the sentence I impose upon you there
will be a sentence of custody for life
the risks around you albeit as a young
man are clear and concerning
the way in which you say some things to
professionals and yet say the contrary
to others means that there is my
judgment no clear picture of when those
risks May abate
that position supports my decision as to
dangerousness leading to custody for
life
you have pleaded guilty your plea
warrants a reduction in a sentence would
otherwise have been passed
having reflected on the submissions made
this morning the appropriate reduction
in your cases is one-third
having considered what would otherwise
be the appropriate categorizationist
case and the impact of the aggravating
and mitigating features including age
and maturity the appropriate sentence
and minimum term as I indicate would be
one of nine years custody allowing for
your plea a minimum term of six years
there is now no early release for
terrorist offenders that minimum term is
the same as what was used to be called
the determinant term the days on Ramon
which I'm told number 367 days will
count towards that sentence and so the
sentence of this chord is one of custody
for life with a minimum of six years
less 360 seven days
what that means is this that before you
will be first considered for parole
there will be a period of six years less
367 days if the information which I've
been provided as the days on Roman
proves to be inaccurate
the prosecution or defense must notify
the court so that the case can be
re-listed to correct that calculation as
soon as possible and in any event within
56 days
when it comes to the minimum term you
will serve I make plain that I am not
ordering that you are to be released at
the end of it whether you'll be released
or not at that stage or at any later
stage will be a matter for the parole
board to consider only when the minimum
term has been served can the parole will
decide whether it is safe to release you
or not
if the board does release you you remain
on license and liable to recall for the
rest of your life
if the stat Reserve charge applies to
your case then the appropriate orders
can be drawn up I order the forfeiture
under section 23 of the charismat 2000
of four items rjb1 a mobile phone
rjb2 a laptop rjb 23 tactical combat
plugs and rjb20 tactical combat goggles
you will be subject to notification
requirements as set out in the
counterterrorism act 2008.
you may go down